-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show." Um...
[ Laughter ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
Måneskin
is performing tonight, okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is a true story.
This morning, we found out
their bass player, Vic,
couldn't be here
because she got sick.
She's fine, but they need
a bass player.
They needed a bass player.
So...they asked me
if I could play.
This is true. It happened
this morning at, like, 11:00.
And I'm like, "How do you play
it? What is it? I don't know."
And they were like --
they showed it to me.
So I got it.
It's like...
♪♪
So I have that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I said, "I can do this.
I can rock that, and I can
go loud. Let's go for it."
I'm gonna do this for Vic, okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna do this
for rock 'n' roll!
[ Drumroll ]
And I'm gonna do this
for the world!
Ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform their new song
"SUPERMODEL,"
please welcome Måneskin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ah-ah-ah, alone at parties
in a deadly silhouette ♪
♪ She loves the cocaine, but
cocaine don't love her back ♪
♪ When she's upset, she talks to
Maury and takes deep breaths ♪
♪ She's a '90s supermodel,
uh-uh-uh ♪
♪ Way back in high school,
when she was a good Christian ♪
♪ I used to know her, but she's
got a new best friend ♪
♪ A drag queen named The Virgin
Mary takes confessions ♪
♪ She's a '90s supermodel ♪
♪ Yeah, she's a master,
my compliments ♪
♪ If you wanna love her,
just deal with that ♪
♪ She'll never love you more
than money and cigarettes ♪
♪ Every night's a heartbreak ♪
♪ Hey, don't think about it,
hey, just let it go ♪
♪ 'Cause her boyfriend
is the rock 'n' roll, hey ♪
♪ Savor every moment
'til she has to go ♪
♪ 'Cause her boyfriend
is the rock 'n' roll, ahh ♪
[ Guitar solo ]
♪♪
♪ Alone at parties,
she's working around the clock ♪
♪ When you're not looking,
she's stealing your Basquiat ♪
♪ Low-waisted pants on OnlyFans,
I'll pay for that ♪
♪ She's a '90s supermodel ♪
♪ Ooh, yeah, she's a master,
my compliments ♪
♪ If you wanna love her,
just deal with that ♪
♪ She'll never love you, you
just look a bit like her dad ♪
♪ Yeah, every night's
a heartbreak ♪
♪ Hey, don't think about it,
hey, just let it go ♪
♪ 'Cause her boyfriend
is the rock 'n' roll, hey ♪
♪ Savor every moment
'til she has to go ♪
♪ 'Cause her boyfriend
is the rock 'n' roll, ah ♪
♪ Yeah, now ♪
♪ She's a '90s supermodel,
uh-uh-uh ♪
♪♪
♪ She's a '90s supermodel,
uh-uh-uh ♪
Thank you, Jimmy.
-Aaaah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Måneskin!
-And Jimmy Fallon.
-"SUPERMODEL" is out now!